The Joe Rogan experience. Yeah. That's
called theirs. I think they should bring,
they shouldn't, you know how hockey that
you still fighting hockey? Nascar fights.
Yeah. Pull out in the pit. Stop
wants Duke it out. Let's, yeah,
let's say if there's a caution. Everyone
else was lapping. You've got two guys.
Have a beef pullover. Get out of the car.
Whoa. In the middle of the infield grass,
we have a wrestling rink and it's like
full on. Let's go get in the rink.
We'll get it, we'll give you two
minutes. And then if you win that match,
maybe you get a little time
shaving off. You know? So it's uh,
there's advantage to, uh, I'd watched
that more if it were like half wrestling,
half now put the Natya leap, right.
Mascot Nascar's a weird one, right?
Because it's, it's obviously fun to watch.
It's fun to be there, but it's not as fun
as Formula One. You Watch Formula One,
you're like, well, these guys are going
way faster when those wheels. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, that's a whole nother thing.
Yeah. Those wheels touch. It's over.
You're in the air right now.
Yeah. These guys now is called.
A lot of that happens and it's fine.
It's true that one wheel. Wow. Yeah.
And those guys die. Yeah. Well I
guess Nascar guys did too. Yeah.
Not as much anymore, but mean anybody's
driving a fucking car going fast can die.
What am I saying?
But there's something about,
have you ever see the video between um,
they showed gt three race racing
versus formula one racing.
It's the same track and they
show a good gt three car look,
a Porsche going around this car really
fast and then they show the same exact
path being taken by a formula one
car. And you're like, Jesus watches
watches. Yeah. One on the left,
the tool and won't how much faster
they are now. What's the Oh, okay.
That's the same track as the same track.
Exact same turn.
Look how much goddamn faster.
They are bad at it so far.
Is that car going on the right?
I don't know, man. That's insane.
It seems amazing and perfect line.
He's cutting.
See how the line perfect racing
line is cut into the groove.
Like you see that darkness. Yup. Yup.
That's a bunch of talented drivers.
Another thank you.
I think the fastest I've
ever been is like maybe 115.
You ever been on a racetrack? I've been
on a race track. Yeah. Yeah. But not,
you know, not at a pace car, you
know. Oh, the Nascar. Yeah. Yeah.
But uh, but the Daytona 500
has that huge, you know,
the incline and just being down there
and seeing that standing there next to it
like, well, I didn't know his best steep.
You have to go faster and stay
on that then that is pretty wild.
And people get hit up there.
They bump wheels up there and
collide and fucking spin out. Yeah.
Look at that thing. Yeah.
Yeah. That's a serious bank,
like a wall that is a little turn to
the picture, but still. What is, um,
what do you think that degree is? Like
what angle? Uh, they've told me before,
I forgot. It's probably
like, it's pretty serious.
20 degrees first one third or one degree.
One degree. Whoa. Wow. That's crazy.
That's insane. That's, I mean,
if you would be nervous if you're
on a skateboard on that thing,
you have to go a certain speed just to
stay up on the probably, right. Yeah.
It's such an American sport,
man.
Nascar's so American because it's allowed
as fuck. Yeah. The cars are gross. Yeah.
They look to Scott. They're
so gross looking. Yeah.
They don't look anything
like the real car. How many
sponsors are all right? Yeah.
If you have a really nice car that's
supposed to be the model that that car is
and that the Cask, our car
looks gross and they, the decal,
they make fake headlights.
It's a sticker of the head.
I won't even put that on there. Yeah. What
are we doing? Why are you lying to me?
Yeah.
It's a fascinating piece
of equipment though. Yeah.
That we've decided to make these things
that just drive really fast and then
hurl them around the circle,
this oval over and over and
so high tech, like every,
they count every little, the drafting
of it, they, they know it. Every angle.
It's, you know, all of
that. But back in the day,
it was just a couple of good old boys.
That moonshine.
I'm trying to outrun this actually.
Yeah. That's actually what I want to say.
That was hot rodding and it's
fine. It's, that's what it was.
That's what I want to say. Put money
down in them cars and that fun that,
that's where it all came from.
Yes.
Guys are trying to figure out how
to get the fuck away from cops.
Cops used to have the
fanciest cars, man. Yeah.
You think that they had to chase
people and like caprice classics
with Bob Bench seats? Yeah. That is the
worst car from handling with dress shoes.
Yeah. Oh my God. They make them
wear a stupid shoes. Yeah. Yeah.
Some Nike's that's back in the day.
That's like the fur on the beach while
I taught I was on the ocean was Daytona
500 the first event. Uh, you know, I
think so. I think, well, I'm not, no,
I don't know about that, but I know
that's, it was on the, on the sand. Okay.
The first Daytona was on the sand. I
believe she's around the sand. Yeah,
they're driving in the sand. This
is crazy. They're not going as fast.
All those cars are social, convertible.
It looks like the Batmobile.
They are convertibles. Convertibles.
Wow. That's what I want to see.
I'll bring back the dam convertible in
Nascar. I want to see these dudes faces.
Wonder why they made them in
convertibles? I'd have no, yeah,
well they got the roll
bar. Yeah. But still,
I mean I bet it gets too hot in there
and they probably didn't have air
conditioning. Right. And yeah,
that's probably it was, it's on fire.
It's easier to get out when you
don't have a roof. Yeah. Yeah.
Those people probably died. Those
things all the time. Those shitty cars.
Like if you are a car racer back
then you were going to crash.
There's no way you're going to know.
You're not going to keep
it together every time. Uh,
what's the fastest you think
you've been in a vehicle?
I don't want to say cause we're on
there. Ah, well you know, you say where,
what country it was in. Uh, I don't
know. This could be on Germany,
on the auto mile. In the
one hundreds yeah, yeah.